bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport tout de suite on
passe au sommaire box Le Verrier roi
Ahmed El Moussaoui a conservé son titre
de champion de l'Union européenne des
Walter il a battu au point le
Britannique juniorither se vendredi nous
recevons le champion ivinois dans
quelques minutes dans cette émission
baseball les cougar de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont remporté leur
premier match de la saison à domicile
contre ici en deuxième division plus de
détails à suivre dans ce magazine
football nous ferons le point sur les
bonnes performances du club de Trappes
l'équipe reste sur trois matchs sans
défaite et remonte au classement
interview a suivre avec le président
Mustapha Larbaoui le coach motion ou si
et le défenseur Amidou Sissoko et puis
en fin d'émission comme tous les lundis
nous reviendrons ce résultat sportifs du
week-end mais tout de suite place à
notre première invité
on le surnomme le prince Ahmed El
Moussaoui a conservé son titre de
champion de l'Union européenne des
Walter en battant pour l’anglais junior
8h ce vendredi au Cannet nous recevons
donc ce soir Ahmed El Moussaoui bonsoir
bonsoir donc c'est un honneur de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau alors vous avez
remporté du coup ce combat au point
est-ce que c'était un match compliqué un
combat compliqué
déjà au départ je m'attendais à un
combat compliqué parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est très très compliqué
dans sa box et dans sa manière de boxer
donc c'est parti au point mais je
fallais s'y attendre parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a
très peu de défaites et il a une seule
défaite avant la limite maintenant voilà
c'est c'est un combat serré mais j'ai
fait j'ai fait la petite le petit truc
qui a fait la différence votre
adversaire est également un vieux
briscard et il a notamment remporté le 2
couronnes mondial en 2006 en 2008 est-ce
que c'est un petit peu son expérience du
coup qui vous a gêné dans ce combat
c'est sa manière de boxer aussi son
expérience c'est vrai que vous disiez
que ça boxe c'était vicieuse c'est ça
c'est un truc euh vicieux beaucoup
d'accrochage c'est j'appelle ça un peu
de l'anti box après c'est vrai qu'ils
sont palmarès aussi fait une grosse
différence
il a plus de 50 combats il a été
plusieurs fois champion d'Europe
plusieurs fois champion du monde et ça
c'est ressenti d'ailleurs sur le combat
mais ça m'a pas énormément de s'amuser
le son palmarès mais ce qui m'a plus de
déstabiliser pardon c'est c'est ça tout
simplement sa manière de boxer ses
accrochages
comme vous dites vous êtes encore jeune
est-ce que ce type de combat peut vous
permettre de vous améliorer
bah c'est vrai que j'ai pris énormément
d'expérience sur ce que moi maintenant
j'attends j'attends de voir le prochain
combat c'est tout simplement on va voir
si ça va être à la hauteur de mes
attentes et physiquement vous êtes senti
comment très bien physiquement je sais
très bien maintenant
et j'avais aucun aucun problème de
condition physique j'étais prêt j'ai je
me suis entraîné dur pour ça et c'était
tactique c'était un combat tactique et
quels sont les points du coup que vous
allez vous devez encore améliorer pour
mieux finir vos combats on sait que vous
avez tendance quand même assez dominer
vos combats justement et est-ce que
physiquement on va dire ça va mais
est-ce que le progrès doit se faire au
niveau mental non mentalement je suis
très bien j'ai jamais eu vraiment de
problème mentalement ni physiquement
après maintenant voilà c'est c'est des
étapes par laquelle on passe là c'est
vrai que
tombe sur un adversaire très dur et
compliqué à toucher voilà après je pense
que avec je pense qu'avec un autre
adversaire j'aurais fait plus de
différence donc vous êtes un bilan de 22
victoires dont 5 avant la limite annule
et une défaite vous avez 5 25 ans quels
sont les objectifs justement de à mes
del Moussaoui sur les prochaines années
bah pour le moment à court terme déjà au
moins défendre une fois mon titre et
pourquoi pas faire un championnat majeur
d'ici la rentrée ou la fin de l'année ça
serait bien j'étais classé quatrième
européen juste avant mon combat de
vendredi là je pense que je vais je vais
monter j'espère numéro 1 Voir challenger
donc on verra j'attends vous pour
l'instant pas encore mais
il y a une date à confirmer en juin donc
ça serait bien vous êtes également
entraîné avec enfin même salle que Floyd
Mayweather est-ce que c'est un exemple
pour vous ce boxeur
ça reste ça reste quelqu'un de
ça reste le meilleur boxeur pour moi
actuellement et on a on a tous
qui est très connu l'un des meilleurs
boxeurs actuellement
c'est ça on en vit tous maintenant voilà
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille dur et qui
le mérite tout simplement et est-ce
qu'il est aussi fort qu'on dit il est
très très fort très très fort bah c'est
pour ça qu'il est imbattable enfin pour
le moment mais on verra bien de toute
façon pour son prochain combat du coup
vous avez combattu contre lui
donc c'est juste avec un de ces un de
ces chouchous Adrien bonheur mais je
l'ai vu à l'entraînement plusieurs fois
et c'est vrai que ça reste très
impressionnant et vous a donné quelques
conseils pour pour votre carrière non
pas spécialement après il est un peu
dans une dans une plage on se connait
pas être un peu différent aussi dans sa
manière de boxer d'appréhender les
matchs aussi comment chaque boxeur est
un peu différent dans la manière
d'aborder sa box aussi c'est vrai que la
une box spéciale il est très très fort
défensivement il prend très peu de coup
et je pense que ce boxer tu prends le
monde qu'au monde voilà c'est ce qui
fait sa force aussi donc l'actualité de
la box du coup c'est ce combat entre
Floyd Mayweather et many pacao donc il y
aura lieu le 2 mai à Las Vegas vous qui
connaissez donc les weather est-ce que
vous pensez que que ça sera le favori
sur cette rencontre
moi je donne un petit côté
penchant vers je pense que il va faire
la différence plus plus rapide enfin
plus rapide plus rapide plus précis pour
moi et je veux gagner je veux gagner de
très peu mais je veux gagner après
maintenant voilà c'est vrai que ça reste
ça reste fait de mes heures et puis
c'est pas le non plus le manipulateur de
il y a quelques années donc
ce combat arrive peut-être trop tard un
petit peu pour beaucoup de personnes et
quelles sont les clés du coup de ce
match
il y a pas vraiment
c'est un boxeur offensif et
maintenant Floyd il est plutôt un peu
plus sur la défensive mais qui est un
excellent contrôleur je pense que ça va
ça va aller au point et je vois je vois
au foyer ou pas et est-ce qu'un jour on
pourra peut-être voir Ahmed El Moussaoui
au même niveau qu'il y a un flingue
Mayweather je sais pas ça le l'avenir
nous le dira mais c'est vrai que il faut
il faut du boulot pour ça parce que
c'est ça reste c'est quelqu'un merci à
Madame
on vous souhaite donc de gagner beaucoup
de titres dans les années à venir on
passe maintenant au baseball
les Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ont reçu et signes pour le premier match
de la saison à domicile au stade Jean
maréchal et il monte un se sont inclinés
dans la première manche 11 à 8 les
joueurs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont
ensuite rectifié le tir dans le deuxième
match 10 à 7 le montage est signé romain
russeini
les Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ont lancé leur saison à domicile ce
dimanche pour leur premier match les
imimontants ont accueilli et Sin au
stade de Jean maréchal les cougarer ont
perdu la première partie sur le score de
11 à 8 ils se sont ensuite rattrapés
dans le deuxième acte en remportant le
match 10 à 7 cette rencontre a permis de
jauger le potentiel de l'équipe dans ce
championnat de deuxième division un bon
potentiel oui moi je trouve qu'on a une
belle équipe quoi le secret c'est les
lanceurs si les lanceurs sont en forme
ça va et la frappe si nous on répond à
ton présent il y aurait pas de il y aura
pas de souci mais le championnat assez
je trouve que le championnat il est
assez assez relevé cette année quoi les
équipes ils ont des étrangers
je sais pas si Cuba venezueliens
on est ensemble déjà on fera bien on
défense bien sauf que en hiver on
s'entraînait pas beaucoup en fait donc
j'ai peur un peu après cette année les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
nourrice de grandes ambitions dans ce
championnat la montée en première
division est envisageable au niveau de
notre équipe une qui est en division 2
c'est de au moins atteindre ce qu'on
appelle les play-offs c'est-à-dire au
moins jouer les demi-finales du
championnat de France et essayer de
gagner une place en finale alors
évidemment avoir un titre de champion de
France ça nous conviendrait tout à fait
pour atteindre ses objectifs les cougars
devront gagner les deux prochains matchs
contre Rennes la rencontre est
programmée sur le terrain des Bretons le
dimanche 3 mai
trap n'en finit plus de surprendre en
cette fin de championnat les trappy sont
enchaînés une série de trois victoires
sans perdre avec un match nul contre
l'un des favoris de Promotion d'Honneur
Chatou pour décrypter la bonne dynamique
de Trappes en cette fin de saison le
recevons sur ce plateau Mustapha oui
bonjour donc le président trap motion a
aussi donc le code je trap et également
donc amidouci Soco défenseur alors
Mustapha Larbaoui qu'est-ce qui explique
cette bonne dynamique à ce qu'il
explique ils vont vous le dire c'est sur
le terrain que ça se passe moi je suis
président je préside il joue donc je
vais leur donner la parole mais en
réalité alors du coup
cette bonne dynamique en expliquant
de tout un travail qui a été fait depuis
le début de saison ces derniers temps
n'a fait pas mal de match nuls on a pris
de nos erreurs et le travail commence à
payer et un groupe qui est homogène avec
un mélange d'anciens et de jeunes
prometteur à midi Soko qu'est-ce qu'il
fait la force de l'équipe
je pense qu'à un moment on a pris
conscience de notre potentiel
vu qu'on était pas très loin de la
descente on s'est on se mobilisé
je pense que ça ça a fait la différence
on a pris conscience de nos qualités et
on s'est mis au travail justement
l'équipe était comme le disait
au bord de la de la relégation qu'est-ce
qui a qu'est-ce qui a changé dans
l'équipe il y a eu un déclic peut-être
il y a quelques semaines non après j'ai
changé peut-être votre coaching
pas spécialement il y a eu une revue
d'effectif que qui a été fait et l'état
d'esprit actuellement est bon des
joueurs se se démènent sur le terrain
l'état d'esprit comme je dis les états
d'esprit est très bon et c'est ça qui
fait notre force
à midi aussi Soco justement à ce qu'il y
a des joueurs qui qui tirent le groupe
vers le haut des joueurs qui font la
différence sur le terrain bien sûr on a
trois ou quatre leaders qui qui sont
dans l'équipe qui tirent l'équipe vers
le haut parleur sérieux leur
investissement et après derrière on est
obligé de suivre vous avez notamment le
deuxième c'est ça deuxième meilleur
buteur du championnat
Balthazar qui qui nous fait énormément
de bien cette année donc lui il a joué
durant les années précédentes plus haut
et avec son expérience il nous fait
beaucoup de bien et justement ce joueur
peut tirer le gouver le haut c'est c'est
vraiment le leader de l'équipe où c'est
vraiment un collectif cette équipe de
Trappes en fait on a un collectif avec
certains joueurs qui sont des leaders
techniques
et des leaders de vestiaires et on a
surtout beaucoup de jeunes prometteurs
qui apprennent qu'on a un groupe qui est
assez jeune avec une moyenne d'âge de 24
ans il y a plus de 10 joueurs
d'effectifs qui ont moins de 23 ans
c'est à dire que il y a un vivier au
sein du club plus l'autre partie avec
des joueurs un peu plus matures qui
permettent d'encadrer tout ça moi ça
falloir qu'est-ce que vous pensez
justement de cette bonne dynamique
justement et dans une enfin construit
quelque chose en ce moment ouais pour le
coup je pense que les résultats parlent
un moment donné on a tous des discours
mais c'est vrai que les résultats c'est
factuels on a commencé on a eu quasiment
9 matchs nuls cette année et les matchs
nuls sont très pénalisant ouais c'est
très symptomatique le match nul mais
c'est vrai que depuis les trois derniers
matchs on a les résultats et ça ça va
complètement dans le sens de ce que de
ce qu'on dit match et Amidou et en même
temps c'est vrai que c'est une prise de
conscience à la fois des seniors mais en
même temps
au sein du club c'est une construction
le club et on est parti sur les sur les
sur les fondamentaux donc on est parti
de l'école de foot et on a bâti
gentiment les 15 des 17 et 19 et
aujourd'hui les seniors sont vraiment à
se dire que il faut qu'il concrétise
aussi quelque chose au sein du collectif
donc c'est à la fois un collectif équipe
de foot donc leur équipe les seniors
faut parler également de la baie qui a
beaucoup contribué et qui est plutôt en
délicatesse mais qui a beaucoup
contribué la C qui a contribué aussi la
même façon qui pratiquement sur une
montée voilà donc c'est un gros gros
collectif je rappelle que le club de
foot de trap c'est plus de 1000 plus de
1000 adhérents et il y a un vrai esprit
familial il faut venir dans les tournois
les tournois de 8-9 les tournois U13 U14
il y a vraiment voilà ce collectif c'est
une vraie famille c'est un vrai boulot
et tout le monde a conscient de tout ce
qui se passe à la fois
je pense je pense pouvoir le dire
maintenant il y a vraiment vraiment un
collectif au sens le plus le plus noble
du terme voilà le sport est un sport
actif le foot mais là pour le coup trap
c'est vraiment cette dynamique qu'on
retrouve que vous retrouvez avec les
féminines maintenant qui sont avec un
noyau qui vient de se constituer on
devrait retrouver de l'année prochaine
un terrain synthétique qui va nous
permettre de travailler dans de
meilleures conditions plus de 1000
adhérents sur deux trois terrains de
foot c'est inacceptable et ça tout le
monde le sait maintenant tout le monde a
conscience il y a un terrain de foot qui
va arriver en septembre ils vont pouvoir
jouer parce qu'il le disent pas mais il
joue sur un demi terrain il joue dans
des conditions extrêmes ils jouent sur
des conditions absolument déplorables
mais voilà la conscience elle est
d'abord dans la tête et ensuite voilà
matériellement ils ont ils auront ce
qu'il faut l'année prochaine et j'en
profite pour les remercier j'en profite
pour les saluer à l'antenne pour
remercier tous les éducateurs tous les
Trappistes qui font confiance et c'est
sur le long terme compatible le club
mode a aussi justement ce
cette bonne dynamique est-ce qu'elle
peut vous propulser aux trois premières
places vous êtes à 5 points actuellement
est-ce qu'on peut accrocher ce podium
après on va essayer de finir en beauté
de continuer sur la dynamique qu'on a il
nous reste quatre matchs dont deux à la
maison de à l'extérieur on va aller
chercher les points pour bien finir la
vidéo Sissoko c'est jouable
on va essayer de faire sauter la banque
du président et
justement coach vous vous préparez
peut-être psychologiquement votre équipe
avant le match là vous leur dites quoi
là en ce moment à vos joueurs il faut
accrocher justement ce podium
pense que ils savent ce qu'ils ont à
faire on a assez discuté depuis le début
de la saison on a tous pris nos
responsabilités ça commence par le
terrain après leur faire de la
littérature leur expliquer pas mal de
choses c'est eux qui jouent on met un
système en place c'est eux qui l'anime
donc les résultats sont à l'image de
leur travail c'est eux qui vous
remercier parce que c'est eux qui jouent
sur le terrain et la montée elle est
énervée inenvisageable sur ce sur cette
fin de saison honnêtement les deux
premiers
on pourra pas les toucher en quoi qu'il
arrive on pourra pas le toucher on
pourra pas les toucher pourquoi parce
que à chaque fois une défaite c'est un
point ils ont je pense 52 et 51
ça va être compliqué bon moi finir dans
le top 4
est-ce qu'on peut dire quand même que la
saison est réussie au final elle est
réussie parce que chaque année il y a
quelque chose qui est apporté au club la
pierre à l'édifice chaque année il se
passe quelque chose et encore une fois
j'ai dû le dire plusieurs fois sur cette
antenne d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
dire que TV fils 78 nous
rend hommage souvent nous les sportifs
dans votre émission mais et c'est vrai
qu'on a des besoins de reconnaissance
dans les clubs de foot etc vous nous
l'apportez j'en profite pour le dire au
passage mais chaque année il se prépare
il se propose quelque chose il nous
propose quelque chose il nous apporte
quelque chose les résultats c'est
important la résultante et les d'autant
plus et donc l'année prochaine ça se
prépare dès maintenant à l'année
prochaine c'est déjà préparé c'est déjà
dans les c'est déjà dans les dans les
cartons c'est déjà dans nos têtes et
voilà donc aujourd'hui les matchs tous
les matchs qu'on fait maintenant sont
déjà pour l'année prochaine bien sûr et
match
ce mercato vous le préparez déjà vous
avez déjà
quelques postes peut-être non j'attends
la fin de saison j'attends la fin de
saison
faut pas trop se disperser on a un
objectif c'est bien finir après on verra
vous préparez donc dès maintenant la
saison prochaine on commence quel
président oui parce qu'il y a des choses
à organiser il y a des choses à mettre
en place il y a des il y a des
fondements qu'il faut modifier un
minimum c'est comme un pilotage d'avion
un moment donné faut faut gérer la
trajectoire moi ma trajectoire elle est
sur cinq ans en revanche nos amis là ils
sont tous les matchs ils vont chercher
match après match et on se soucie pas
tout à fait du match suivant on est
vraiment match après match en ce qui
concerne un président ouais pour le club
on est à préparer bien sûr l'année
prochaine voir quasiment les années
d'après puisque on prépare également
l'Académie l'Académie sur lequel on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler à la
rentrée mais où on fait du soutien du
suivi scolaire et c'est des choses qui
apportent au foot et qui apportent à nos
individus donc c'est bon pour tout le
monde et vous avez assez de subventions
pour pour construire ce club offre juste
pas qu'on en parle si c'est un débat que
j'ouvre maintenant vous avez juste le
regretter on a perdu 23000 euros de
subventions l'année dernière on est
constamment comme toutes les
collectivités locales sur des baisses de
subventions on est on est touché comme
tout le monde je crois pouvoir dire pas
plus pas moins et donc ça suppose de
gérer ouais avec aussi des baisses de
subventions mais voilà je vais pas
ouvrir le débat ici mais c'est pas
qu'une question d'argent tout le temps
c'est pas qu'une question de subvention
il y a un vrai travail de motivation
aussi à faire il y a un vrai travail
voilà où on va chercher allez
osons le terme en termes de productivité
c'est-à-dire que chacun apporte le
maximum de ce qui peut apporter que ça
soit dans une équipe de foot que ça soit
les dirigeants que ça soit les gens qui
m'assistent on fait que moi on essaie de
faire mieux quand même
merci à tous les trois d'être passé sur
ce plateau on vous souhaite en tout cas
bon courage pour cette fin de saison et
pourquoi pas du coup accrocher le podium
on passe maintenant à l'Ultimate
la onzième édition du tournoi d'Ultimate
de plaisir était organisé ce week-end au
Palais des Sports Pierre de Coubertin 8
équipes et plus de 80 joueurs ont
participé à la compétition les images
sont signées Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
l'ultime était étalonneur ce week-end à
plaisir ce sport collectif originaire
des États-Unis se joue avec un frisbee
le principe les joueurs doivent
progresser sur le terrain en faisant des
passes un point est marqué quand un
joueur réceptionne le disque dans la
zone adverse pour ça onzième édition le
tournoi réunit près de 8 équipes et 80
joueurs au Palais des Sports j'ai trouvé
ma partie que cette année le niveau
c'est un peu relevé niveau et de plus en
plus fort on nous on touche surtout les
équipes des Yvelines alors déjà que le
niveau est assez fort dans les Yvelines
ça fait que le niveau est fort et bien
que ce week-end il y a un championnat de
National 1 donc les tops joueurs
français ne sont peut-être pas ici mais
le niveau a été très bon ce week-end
dans le public une quarantaine de
passionnés est venu profiter du
spectacle sur les deux jours de
compétition on adore l'ambiance c'est un
tournoi amical on est là pour le sport
pas pour la compétition c'est vraiment
pour le jeu le le fun quoi c'est comme
tous les ans c'est bien ces choses ça
dure jusqu'à la dernière minute
sur le terrain les Scud on fait le show
l'équipe est arrivé première du tournoi
avec deux Yvelines dans sa sélection
plaisir à terminer à l'avant-dernière
place cette victoire on s'est vraiment
accrochée pour l'avoir
on avait on avait déjà eu un match qu'on
a perdu contre l'Essonne d'un point on
s'est dit qu'il est qu'il fallait
vraiment tout donner et donc on est
content d'avoir donné le meilleur de
nous-mêmes les skudes remettront leur
titre en jeu l'année prochaine la 12e
édition du tournoi de plaisir est déjà
programmée pour avril 2016
après le ultimate on passe aux autres
résultats du weekend
on commence cette page résultat par du
rugby fin de l'aventure en Fédérale 2
pour plaisir les Yvelines a joué ce
dimanche leur survie dans ce championnat
sur le terrain de Domont les plaisirs
rois n'ont pas réussi à créer l'exploits
se sont inclinés de justesse 17 à 9
conséquent au classement plaisir termine
la saison avec 17 points en 18 journées
c'est si de moins que son adversaire du
jour Domont qui reste donc en fédéral 2
le championnat a été remporté par Rouen
qui totalise 78 points
toujours en bas mais cette fois-ci chez
les garçons le chêné c'est incliné une
nouvelle fois en National 3 et chez
nezia ont perdu contre plutôt sur le
score de 26 à 23 c'est une nouvelle fois
la défense qui n'a pas répondu présente
dans la rencontre le championnat est
toujours dominé par Lille Le Chesnay et
relégal à 3e place Morsang ferry leur
passe devant grâce à leur victoire
contre Aubervilliers
en football manyla Mounia arrive plus en
deuxième division de district les Magny
quoi en concédé une nouvelle défaite de
zéro sur le terrain du chiné ce week-end
dans les autres matchs les clés souvent
ont étriers le PEC sur le score de 6 à 1
et Montigny-le-Bretonneux arraché le
match nul sur le terrain de voisin score
final trois partout au classement Magny
Lamo perd la première place le
championnat est maintenant dominé par
les clés sous bois avec 62 points
et puis et puis un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer ce week-end les Templiers
d'alencourt reçoivent le flash de La
Courneuve au complexe sportif Europe les
élèves en courtois ont mal débuté leur
saison mais il reste sur trois victoires
consécutives une victoire contre le
flash pourrait permettre aux
élancourtois de se replacer dans la
course aux places européennes
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 sport merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
magazine passez une excellente semaine
sportive très bonne soirée sur tvfils 78